5 45 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well i think i can
already hear people saying amen to this
email about the ongoing work on the
southern 215 beltway robert writes
they've added an extra lane on both
north and southbound sides but they
still keep the southbound side close do
they think the south side doesn't jam
up well it does what's up ndot well
robert there is a lot of work done
and still plan for the 215 beltway when
it comes to who's doing that work it
depends on which part of the 215 you're
talking about
so east of the i-15 the 215 is an
interstate all the way over the 93-95
i-11 so it's called i-215
west of the 15. i hope you notice how
the sign looks different and this is a
part of the beltway that goes all the
way up and around to where it meets the
i-15 or the speedway
technically it is clark county 215 well
two of the biggest ongoing projects the
widening between charleston that's down
towards durango
and the other one is that ongoing work
the stretch between decatur and i-15
all that work is being done by clark
county and they say they want it to be
done by the fall
oh by the way there are some specific
nighttime lane and ramp closures through
friday morning
and they are on our website eight
newsnow dot com you click traffic then
click driving you crazy
robert thank you for writing in the
meantime please buckle up drive
carefully and put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
just email me and send your pictures and
video to the same email address
traffic 8 8 news now dot com